[Música]
en France 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy Valentina
Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos iniciamos con un hito en
una cirugía de trasplante pulmonar un
equipo del hospital valdebro donde
Barcelona hizo historia al realizar por
primera vez este procedimiento
quirúrgico empleando el famoso robot Da
Vinci y sin abrir el tórax como
tradicionalmente se hace Por qué no
utilizamos la cirugía robótica con
pequeñas incisiones y una incisión muy
pequeña debajo del esternón por donde
Podríamos sacar el órgano enfermo e
introducir el órgano donado creemos que
es una técnica que va a mejorar la
calidad de vida de los pacientes que va
a mejorar el postoperatorio que va a
mejorar el dolor que tienen los
pacientes la cirugía fue realizada en un
paciente de 65 años con fibrosis
pulmonar y se reemplazó un solo órgano
pero el centro trabaja para poder
realizar este tipo de procedimiento
bipolar algunos meses esto Dijo Xavier
el primer beneficiario de la técnica
para mí el dolor ha sido cero lo que sí
Ahora estoy muy contento que lo hayan
hecho así que haya funcionado y que todo
el sistema se pueda beneficiar de una
mejora tan cualitativa en cuanto al tema
de la precisión y de las consecuencias
de dolor y de traumatismo que se generan
cambiamos de tema porque científicos y
estudiantes de la Universidad de tel
aviv demostraron que las plantas emiten
señales acústicas cuando están
estresadas ya sea por falta de riego
infecciones o cortes este equipo israelí
logró algo inédito por primera vez estos
ultrasonidos que los humanos no podemos
percibir fueron grabados e identificados
con ayuda de un programa de Inteligencia
artificial nuestros corresponsales en
Jerusalén en Federico cuevar varena y
Yanira Gómez Muñoz vieron de cerca los
resultados
en este pequeño invernadero de la
Universidad de tel aviv la biólogani y
su equipo revelaron un gran hallazgo las
plantas emiten sonidos son ultrasónicos
es decir escapan al oído humano y se
producen sobre todo en momentos de
estrés como la poda o la deshidratación
lo dices de Sounds Este es el sonido de
una planta de Beat luego de haber sido
cortada una planta cortada emite este
tipo de sonido que fue grabado durante
una hora convertido a un Rango audible
para los humanos y condensado
estos chasquidos se originan en los
tallos posiblemente por la explosión
interna de burbujas de aire durante el
transporte de agua aunque no todo suenan
igual ni con la misma intensidad
cada tomatera planta de tabaco o trigo
analizado por este equipo israelí
mostraron frecuencias diversas
registradas con micrófonos sensibles al
ultrasonido e interpretadas mediante
Inteligencia artificial
al algoritmo se le daba un montón de
información que está etiquetada también
lo entrenamos para distinguir entre una
planta de tomate y otra de tabaco así
como entre una tomatera seca una cortada
y una severamente seca A mayor cantidad
de ejemplos mayor precisión
si bien no es una acción consciente los
sonidos de las plantas se transmiten
información al igual que cuando sus
hojas se secan para hadani ahora el reto
es saber si otras congéneres O animales
responden a ellos por ejemplo una
polilla que busca un lugar para poner
sus huevos va a preferir una planta que
emite sonidos o una que no si una planta
puede recibir indicaciones de otras
cercanas que están estresadas podría ser
muy útil también podría favorecer
actividades como la agricultura
si identificaremos con una planta
necesita agua según sus sonidos
podríamos tener una Irrigación más
adecuada y quizás en unos años hasta
podríamos ver pequeños detectores de
estrés cerca de plantas de hogar
indicando que necesitan agua toda una
sorpresa para Los amantes de las plantas
acostumbrados a hablarles pero ignorando
hasta ahora que hechas también les
hablan
continuamos hablando de Inteligencia
artificial Porque existe un debate sobre
si el arte generado por esta tecnología
se puede considerar realmente arte uno
de los casos más recientes es el del
fotógrafo alemán Boris el daxen que
presentó una imagen creada con
Inteligencia artificial e incluso ganó
un premio al competir con otras imágenes
que sí habían sido tomadas de forma
tradicional veamos la historia
este retrato parece haber sido tomado
por una persona viva Pero no fue así fue
creado usando Inteligencia artificial y
quién lo hubiera imaginado ganó el
primer premio en un prestigioso concurso
de Sony
me sorprendió ganar me sorprendió
también que le dije al Jurado Que la
foto fue generada por Inteligencia
artificial y sugerí que necesitamos
tener una discusión sobre esto y las
imágenes con esta tecnología no deberían
competir en la misma categoría esta
sugerencia no fue respondida
[Música]
rechazó el premio argumentando que sólo
inscribió la foto para acelerar el
debate sobre el uso de la Inteligencia
artificial en la industria esta
tecnología está siendo usada para robar
su arte Karla Ortiz una ilustradora que
reside en San Francisco está preocupada
estoy empezando a ver que la
Inteligencia artificial invade mi
industria he escuchado muchos reportes
de artistas alrededor del mundo que han
perdido comisiones por esto pasa
rápidamente y es sorprendente porque la
legalidad de estos productos aún no se
ha determinado mientras que muchos
artistas ven La Inteligencia artificial
como una competencia otros la consideran
una herramienta el mes pasado llegó a
las estanterías el primer manga dibujado
por Inteligencia artificial el autor que
se hace Llamar Ruth Port y que esconde
su identidad con un avatar admite que
recurrió a la Inteligencia artificial
porque no tenía absolutamente ningún
talento para dibujar
puedo decir que el dibujo de
Inteligencia artificial es mucho más
rápido que cualquier dibujo manual
mientras que una ilustración a todo
color lleva un artista un día completo
no importa lo rápido que la persona
dibuje esta herramienta termina en un
minuto o algo así Creo que esto es una
Clara ventaja
impresionante quizás pero también hubo
una gran reacción con muchos en la
industria preocupados por el impacto que
esta tecnología tendrá en su creatividad
e integridad
así concluimos este espacio a ustedes
Les agradecemos su sintonía continúe con
nosotros en France 24 y 24 punto com
[Música]